même aux messieurs nous avons le plaisir
et l'honneur d'accueillir sur notre
plateau un des plus grands virtuoses de
la moule est un un des grands maîtres de
l'art tauromachique moderne
j'ai nommé le grand torero el djou bière
bonjour elle tenir au sud de la seine on
vous appelle l nation gayraud tiens vous
êtes le seul torero d'issy les
moulineaux
c est un souhait cher
comment vous est venue cette vocation à
la rocade tome voulait pas de quels
commentaires vous pouvez parler en
français marcel henry djeddah coeur je
m'appelle donc mars un chantier et je
suis né dans près des dunes et griefs
chez les moulineaux et sous les étoiles
et être utile dont j'allais en vacances
chez mon pépère mais à en espagne dans
dylan à ploubalay
si vous avez des cochons et alors que
j'aurais à cochons alors moi sur les jus
de thé départementaux sur la tête on
faire du code à et le soir conduisant
même joli piqué les fesses et des élus
la tripotée de même ce qui est en
quelque sorte la préfiguration de la
pose des banderilles dans le plus pur
style au nom dans les fesses je vous ai
dit alors si vous voulez donc à la noël
comme j'avais une bonne note en quêté
schiste mon père m'a permis de tuer le
cochon mois de mars que j'ai donc faire
une captation de 25 par 50 ans qu'un
clou rouillé au bout alors j'ai mis
trois heures à la descente mais je vais
lui la [ __ ]
c'est la victoire de l'homme sur la bête
que vous avez concrétiser ce jour là qui
a été pour vous la révélation watch mais
en fait c'est plutôt les boyaux à l'air
est très petit santé mauvais le sens que
vous êtes tarder au delà je me suis dit
marcel tu seras période
pardon
toréador allez vous former en espagne
non c'est à dire il faut dire que
j'avais par une douzaine de formation de
tony traité ce qui va encore une bien
l'aider dans son métier il alors après
ça a été le grand voyage vers le sud
oui c'est ça dans le sud de la seine où
est donc passé un an à blanc où j'ai
fait mes premières torride un
appartement avec des lapins
et oui puisque malheureusement un décret
d'application inique le décret 14 78 de
la loi du 14 juillet 1946 pro ivre nord
de la loire
la pratique de l'art tauromachique alors
après je suis donc descendu vers le sud
en espagne et dans le père et d'orge
effets des premières corridas à l'air
libre avec des joies pas trop dur les
oies d'ailleurs j'aime les corps et mon
marteau épinards en face 7e rencontre
avec le cordobès dites moi elle tombe
bien la lutte que vous menez contre
saivet est seul dans l'arène
c'est un petit peu une lutte contre vous
même endroit mais je suis pas fou
bandoulière un congé en bestiaux ces
belles choses que je sois ne sais pas
vraiment
est ce que vous avez eu peur la première
fois que vous êtes retrouvé seul en face
d'un vrai taureau c'est à dire si vous
voulez quand on est habitué à la volage
bon ben ça ça change c'est sûr ça y'a
pas de problème le gabarit et malgré
elle mais si vous les jeunes avantage
c'est que le taureau ils veulent pas à
ce qui fait qu'on peut rattraper plus
facilement y connait dessus sans
problème comment vous n'avez pas d'épée
c'est à dire je lui ai prêté dans mon
beau frère qui est bouché les secours
ceci dit bon méchant j'ai pu récupérer
son tranchoir alors justement à ce
propos elle tombe hierro je voulais vous
poser la question qui brûle les lèvres
de tous les aficionados de la haute
bretagne et basse-normandie en
particulier comment avez vous fait pour
révolutionner à ce point art
tauromachique
on vous a vu encore récemment je vois
c'est dimanche dernier au zoo de
vincennes
vous avez tord et paraguay il ne faut
pas être man show
ouais petites remarques techniques
quand on travaille à part on dit pas
tord n est pas ébruiter suis-je bête
comme on n'y avait pas pensé plus tôt ça
n'est sorti de l'idée c'est complètement
absurde ça n'est pas trop difficile de
torts et un pingouin pas de pad minella
torons de pin pin et c'est pour ça que
je me suis formé seaway sur la vague et
surtout alors si vous voulez le paraguay
en fait si vous voulez lire semble à
l'abri à cause de qui là si vous voulez
des plumes et des palmes pareil mais il
ressemble au taureau à cause du tibet de
la même couleur si vous voulez pour le
pingouin je me suis laissé dire elles
sont guère ou que vous n'utilisiez pas
des banderilles traditionnels non non
jumeaux lance des fers à repasser
multicolores je suis balancée sur la
gueule ça peut aussi bien que le mans
janvier rendant les corridas
traditionnel le torero qui a fait une
belle corrida se voit attribuer en
récompense les oreilles et la queue mais
vous lorsque vous avez bien pinguin et
qu'est-ce que vous recevez le conduit en
reste comment ça les restes oui parce
que si on les bronzes jades termina par
édouard et le tranchoir la fois que je
viens me lancer des fleurs à presser sur
la gueule je voulais me reste pas grand
chose
alors bon ben je récupère tout ça dans
un sac plastique que ça me déborah pas
du soir
une dernière question et ce sera notre
conclusion elles sont biéreau la corrida
un exemple pour la jeunesse
je veux parce que si vous voulez mon
avis bon en ce moment est situé à
l'époque condé c'est ça va mal de
partout ah bon selon lui les jeunes
c'est nul à vannes ils veulent plus
travailler ils ont plus d'idéal et moi
ce que je voudrais leur montrer aux
jeunes parce que je voudrais leur dire
c'est ja ja m déshonneur a écrasé a plus
fait que soi allez merci